bootleg cab show special guests in here
coyotes are here oh feels good to be
back Ricky and Guapo are here welcome
welcome thanks for having me new music
is out bigger than water thicker than
watering that [ __ ] run that [ __ ] up
shit's going crazy already some single
with symbols going crazy shout out to
Simba by the way also the name of a very
random Mac 10 and Fat Joe movie straight
to the VHS back in the day thicker than
water no really oh [ __ ] we ain't even
know that that's the fire no banging
films
anyway look man uh go support uh you
guys have been killing the content thank
you man appreciate it you guys have been
dropping some crazy [ __ ] just raps
and just y'all been doing it doing your
job man thanks sir
um the uh who else on the project
besides symbols is that the only Simba
or the only feature we got uh Swifty
blue on there Cypress
[Music]
Jim Jones on there oh [ __ ] man but
that's a ghost feature that's the ghost
feature well you guys got a lot of fun
yeah don't tell nobody about that one
Emilio is a rapping ass full too yeah
[Music]
yeah did you guys get a certificate from
Swifty
um we did
yeah we got the pass we got it signed
and framed like like next year degree
there's like the Swifty check-in
certification the house is our
graduation photo and then the check-in
yeah there it is look man go support the
new project uh go run it up and uh let's
get right to it man yeah let's go man
let's do it yeah
[ __ ]
yeah she ain't got nothing to offer
except for good looks came through and
Lace me with some thought I told her
good looks did it how I supposed to be
dead her game was textbook I'm from the
land of more bricks and Russell
Westbrook if you talking about business
then we could chitter chatter I want the
world handed to me on a silver platter
could have took the elevator but I took
the ladder working harder than the
competitions all that really matter I
just make it look like it's butter I
pray and take action want to work
without the other I can't be affiliated
with no cookie cutter they got no
identity they copy one another I'll be
low-key shaded in this limo tent I don't
[ __ ] with no one learn how to take a
hint where the [ __ ] were you them days I
couldn't pay the rent now every room I
walk in on the elephant I don't come
from Gucci and Prada I come from bumping
Chalino at the carne asada make them
make a statement like this ain't
Ensenada middle fingers up to all the
Eric Estrada's hey I'm talking about 12
if you ain't get that everything that I
receive yeah imma give back so if you
love me the number so you love back and
if you hate the number had to push a wig
back yeah it's obvious I got a gift you
could rock with me and I really don't
make a diff her Ricky Blanc was fake
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] myth Chopper
splits you down the middle to you to a
spliff and it's the flow that's gonna
make me immortalize your [ __ ] dropped
and all I heard was a bunch of Lies sex
twice a day that's my only form of
exercise my ego's bigger than my fitted
[ __ ] is super-sized hey and it's gonna
keep growing
and I'm Gonna Keep flowing yeah and we
gonna keep going yeah look yeah don't
get the acting funny I'll be jumping to
conclusions if it's [ __ ] you then it's
[ __ ] you I ain't settling or losing once
you call me over [ __ ] hurting for a
bruising I hit it off of perky now she
say I'm so amusing oh she was in line
though I am pretty [ __ ] amazing what
the [ __ ] we doing man oh yeah
Blanco yodies man if you don't know
let's keep it going let's keep it going
yeah
best rap group for live live
yeah yeah I said it to yodie's [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah in this game no one gives you
[ __ ] you gotta take it the biggest
disappointments come from too much
expectation it's funny when you prove
them on they change the conversation
it's what we never make it now they say
congratulations I see through it I'm
falling for manipulation behind that
smile look at their eyes they're full of
hatred they throw out too much cap like
a college graduation there's so much
information but so little education so
they think we're dummies and every time
I play along you let somebody talk and
they reveal just who they are better
listen to them I swear my game is up to
par with the physically or mentally I'm
always down as far it's a chess game
feeling like I'm over at the next game I
think like I'm a billionaire before the
[ __ ] checks came when we make it
treat us how you treated us with less
Fame I remember everyone that played us
like the X Games they flipped Thunder
they saw us down spit on us now that we
the cool kids they wanna come sit with
us but we got a table for two Ricky and
I talked about us in these buildings but
never let us inside they said that we
don't have what it takes then they
decide to say you got the look but you
don't fit in with the rest of them when
you rap you sound too black sound more
Mexican and maybe we could Market you in
that way look at Snow the Product shorty
killing it in that lane huh you're
insinuating we could only make it so far
that if you look like me you can't
compete with Kendrick Lamar we're like
the sun still Shine the monster
brightest and stars when you're the
first of your kind they come with
emotional scars I can't sleep I can't
quit now I'm too deep you can never walk
in my shoes you're too cheap I'm a
coyote don't got time to come mingle
with you sheep when we walk in any room
here and Whisper Like rules it's the
yodies [ __ ] yeah I said best rap group
alive
hey thicker than water
[Music]
hey
hey what up I know you just watched the
crazy freestyle and guess what we got
another one coming out next week and
another one coming out the week after
and it's all presented by our family at
LRG that's right LRG uh first of all
shout out to them because they just
dropped this fire collab with Ewing
Athletics they got the sneakers they got
the sweat suit the T-shirt all that plus
I want to give a big shout out to them
because it is Christmas time and my
promo code at lrg's website is a serious
one you saved 30 off 30 off if you go to
l-r-g.com and use the promo code bootleg
you'll save 30 off whatever the [ __ ] you
want on lrg's website so it's Christmas
time maybe you need some new gear maybe
you need a new jacket maybe you need a
new [ __ ] sweatsuit whatever it is
l-r-g.com we appreciate them for holding
us down use that promo code bootleg save
30 off and we'll see you next week with
another freestyle presented by LRG